windkraft das waren die große hoffnung
für die energiewende in deutschland wir
waren vorreiter in ganz europa auf der
ganzen welt und jetzt stecken wir in der
krise es werden aktuell so wenig
windräder gebaut wie seit 20 jahren
nicht mehr
und warum das wollen wir heute
herausfinden 2009 10 ist der ausbau der
windenergie eingebrochen 2021 könnten
sogar mehr anlagen abgebaut als neu
gebaut werden
die klimaziele können wir so kaum
erreichen trotzdem gibt es auf diese
einfache frage beantworten
brauchen wir mehr windkraft in
deutschland ja wir haben bereits viel zu
viel und windkraft in deutschland
deutschland diskutiert jeder über
windkraft und wären wir auf der einen
seite die man wieder hören wir brauchen
mehr windräder und zwar sehr schnell
gibt auf der anderen seite sehr sehr
lang genehmigungsprozesse und ganz viele
klagen
wir wollen es einfach mal angucken was
sind die argumente der gegner von
windkraft und was haben wir experten
dazu zu sagen was
[Musik]
wir sind hier heute nach marsdorf
gefahren in den hunsrück weil das hier
ist eine vorreiter region in der
energiewende und wir wollen hier heute
eigentlich jemanden treffen der damit
nicht so ganz einverstanden ist und
gegen windkraft protestiert leider ist
er hier noch nicht nur für den jetzt am
besten einfach mal an
also ist schon nicht ungemütlich fast
überall in deutschland wo ein neuer
windpark gebaut werden soll gibt es
protest von bürgerinitiativen obwohl
laut einer repräsentativen umfrage 92
prozent der deutschen für den ausbau der
wind- und sonnenenergie sind die gegner
der windkraft sind gut organisiert es
gibt einen bundesweiten dachverband
namens bei uns kraft und darunter viele
kleine und größere initiative anheuser
den weg gleich treffen ist vorsitzender
des bündnisses energiewende für mensch
und natur
das ist quasi der landesverband von
rheinland pfalz bis gleich besteht schon
müsse die stunde da vorher kommt jetzt
aber ich hierher wir uns jetzt getroffen
haben sie haben ja auch eben schon
erzählt dass wir jetzt einen ausdruck
machen können wo fahren wir denn hin wir
fern zum kloster maria engel port das
kloster hat die bange erwartung dass
demnächst mehrere windräder quasi vor
der klosterpforte aber hoch oben auf dem
berg errichtet werden sollen und dass
man natürlich das ganze ambiente und die
kontemplation die geistliche besinnung
kaputt wir waren das mal anschauen und
steigen mit einem auf dem weg zum
kloster wird klar heran weiser zweifel
entgegen vieler experten stark daran
dass die windkraft unsere zukunft ist
aber glaube sie nicht dass es dass wir
in zeiten des klimawandels energie
wir brauchen
wir sind in einer situation in der wir
unbedingt eine energiewende brauchen die
hätten sie längst schon gebraucht wir
sind viel zu spät dran nur wir zeugen
das pferd von hinten auf wir machen
genau die verkehrten sachen mit
windrädern die drei prozent zum foto
archiv beitragen nicht mehr
damit schaffen wir es nicht damit halten
wir uns nicht auf tatsächlich muss man
hier zwischen strom und energie
unterscheiden 2009 10 war die
windenergie mit 24 prozent erstmals der
wichtigste stromlieferant in deutschland
wenn es um die primär energie geht zu
der auch wärme verkehr und so weiter
gehören sieht es anders aus da waren es
im jahr 2018 tatsächlich 3 prozent es
gibt hier inzwischen eine
bürgerinitiative und die haben sich
natürlich sofort an uns gewendet
wenn hier irgendwo jemand probleme mit
windkraft projekten bekommt wendete er
sich an uns
direkt im kloster eingang erwarten uns
plakate und hinweise auf den protest
gegen den geplanten windpark und während
wir auf den prior des klosters warten
erzählt heran häuser mir dass er etwa
eine halbe stelle in den kampf gegen
windkraft investiert die einzelnen
initiativen sind unabhängig voneinander
und wie sie vorgehen entscheiden sie
selbst und wenn sie fragen haben wenden
sie sich an mich und werden dann nach
bedarf munitioniert mit argumenten aber
auch mit diversen publikationen die wir
haben mit links noch und noch also ich
habe einen elektronischen erste hilfe
kasten sondern ich weiß ja jeder nach
bedarf und vermögen und in der regel ist
es so dass wir ganz simple
mitgliedsbeiträge haben bei uns zahlt im
bündnis jede bürgerinitiative 60 euro im
jahr
aber wir haben projektbezogen hat unsere
kriegskassen bei den einzelnen
bürgerinitiativen beziehungsweise über
das konto des bündnisses das als
gemeinnütziger verein anerkannt ist
läuft da auch eine ganze menge
sie sagen jetzt kriegskasse das ja schon
ein sehr starkes wort es ist gefühlt
ich nenne ich nenne es so gut auf der
anderen seite haben wir eine
millionenschwere projekt ihrer
gesellschaften für die ist das ein
klacks was wir aufbringen können
munition und kriegskasse den gegnern ist
es ernst und sie scheinen gut vernetzt
zu sein
deutschlandweit gibt es über 900
bürgerinitiativen die zahl der klagen
hat sich erhöht die verfahren haben sich
verlängert
hier vor ort wird eine bürgerinitiative
den bau von sechs windanlagen verhindern
geplant wird seit 2000 17 jetzt ist es
die hauptgründe warum sie den bau des
windparks ablehnen sind vor allem
denkmal und naturschutz
außerdem befürchten sie dass sich die
lebensqualität verschlechtern und die
gäste wegbleiben könnten wir sagen wir
wollen unsere rechte in anspruch nehmen
das gefährdet unsere existenz das
gefährdet dass hier leute erholung
kommen können
die ebenfalls sehr wichtig ist wenn du
irgendwo anders geplant werden wäre das
kein problem
also geht den hauptsächlich und es um
das um das bild und das landschaftliche
bild es geht einer setzung das
landschaftliche hilfe am berg setzen die
emissionen lernen bewegung die eben hier
dann das leben stark einschränken würden
und können sie uns mal zeigen wo jetzt
vom kloster aus wenn die anlagen dann
sehen
dann würde sie schon vor dem bus war aus
von hier aus können wir jetzt einfach
mal draußen können sie jetzt vielleicht
einfach mal zeigen weil das system jetzt
hier so in so einem leeren raum oder das
ist wahrscheinlich für die meisten heute
ein bisschen zu schwierig sich das
vorzustellen ungefähr da ist ja schon
mal ein mann sondern linke haben der
straße macht auch lärm wäre jetzt und
windkraftanlage die da irgendwo
hintergrund ist so viel lauter das kommt
noch dazu wenn regelmäßige lernen von
windkraftanlagen mit einer gewissen
stärke zu können
ja das wäre dann nicht mehr hinter dem
haus hören sie dann nicht mehr von der
straße halten sich überall hände raus
aber das zb das da hinten hören das ist
zu weit weg und es wäre es wirklich
bisher so erzählt er mir hat die
initiative über 1200 unterschriften
gesammelt
sie haben bei gesprächen mit gemeinde
und den betreiber neue sicht analysen
angefordert und von den plänen erfahren
haben sie aus der zeitung
ein punkt der immer wieder auftaucht je
schlechter und je später die menschen im
umkreis mit einbezogen werden desto
stärker ist der protest und die spd
jetzt gefordert wir umliegende gemeinden
oder bürger in den gemeinden finanziell
an den windrädern zu beteiligen
das ihnen helfen wäre das wäre für uns
keine lösung weil es eben objektive
gründe gibt weshalb wir gegen dieses
projekts ihn das ist nicht eine frage
wieviel beckham ist dann alles eine
frage
das denkmal schützen die lebensqualität
vor ort enorm beeinträchtigt werden
würden und das versuchen wir zu finden
der kanonikus ist davon überzeugt dass
gegen recht verstoßen wird
wir haben aber betreiber aber wenn
nachgefragt der sieht das ganze anders
die gutachter konnten keine auswirkung
feststellen die den betrieb des klosters
entgegenstehen wir rechnen mit dem
erhalt der genehmigung im zweiten
quartal 20 20 auch dieses beispiel zeigt
ob natur oder denkmalschutz lärm
versteckte kosten wirtschaftliche
unsinnigkeit oder das landschaftsbild in
den augen von windkraft gegnern gibt es
vieles zu kritisieren
und während sie den schleppenden ausbau
feiern sehen andere darin eine fatale
entwicklung zurückgehen waren studio
habe ich mit professor quaschning von
der hochschule für technik und
wirtschaft berlin gesprochen er ist
professor für erneuerbare energien und
für ihn ist alarmstufe rot
also mit dem jetzigen ausbau der solaren
gewiss so dass wir weit über 100 jahre
brauchen um in deutschland wie man nur
drei zu werden wir haben 20 jahre zeit
so viele anlagen müssten wir nach seinen
berechnungen
jahren eigentlich bauen um die
klimaziele zu erreichen und so viel wird
gerade gebaut
welchen der hauptkritikpunkte der
windkraftgegner können sie am ehesten
nachvollziehen gar keinen also um
endlich kann natürlich schon sehen ich
mag so den windkraftanlagen nicht sie
verhindert dass landschaft wird ich
musste ja nicht schön für nicht also das
ist ja geschmackssache also und
windkraftanlagen schön oder nicht
meistens steht ihm irgend ein rapsfeld
dass es ja auch ohne monokultur geht mit
viel pestiziden angebaut wird selbst
wenn sie im wald steht das ist ja mein
großer diskussionspunkt also wie unsere
wälder sind ja in der regel auch
industrie wälder die also hier holz
liefern dann am ende das heißt also sie
steht ja schon in der kulturlandschaft
natürlich muss man irgendwelche
naturschutzgebiete nationalparks ganz
klar da brauchen wir nicht drüber reden
die sollen geschützt bleiben windparks
raus aber wenn man jetzt bei jedem stand
standort bei jedem feld haben es dann
wirklich also ich glaube da ist auch
oftmals der feldhamster oder die der der
rotmilan der mittel zum zweck und findet
irgendwo einen vogel und kann etwas
verändern was man auch so verhindern
würde und dann werden dort jetzt ein
vogelschützer wie sie ihren lebtag noch
nie über irgendwelchen tier und
artenschutz gedanken gemacht
tatsächlich waren naturschutz und die
vögel in der region auch in unsere thema
schwarzstörche eine welt katze und
rotmilane seien gesichtet worden
später geht er an häuser aber auch das
jetzt so das dumme ist ja dass wir als
kritiker dieser energieform gezwungen
werden uns mit vogelkunde zu
beschäftigen weil andere sachen ziehen
einfach nicht mehr in deutschland wir
haben jetzt wirklich eine situation wo
die einzige möglichkeit einen
irrsinnigen windkraft bau zu verhindern
ein rotmilan oder ein schwarzstorch
vorkommen ist es ist eigentlich
lächerlich weil nach dem menschen nicht
gefragt wird aber nachdem also wenn man
jetzt die befürworter fragt dann sagen
die ja genau das nun anders formuliert
die sagen der rotmilan und die störche
die werden vorgeschoben
das heißt der naturschutz mit
vorgeschoben um den ausbau zu sein so
ist das einzige mittel das man uns noch
gelassen als beim menschen schutz gibt
es in deutschland nicht
so ganz stimmt das nicht es gibt die
werden emissionsregeln was zum beispiel
abstände lärmschutz oder den
schattenwurf angeht
und genau mit diesen gründen wird auch
oft geklagt dennoch scheint es am ende
so als tue sich natur und klima
gegenüber verfolger crush mengen sind da
die prioritäten falsch gesetzt
eine windkraftanlage die ich nicht
besorgt ja auch dafür dass ich auf der
anderen seite in den raum grünen strom
abbauen muss dass ich zum beispiel
vielleicht denn den wald oder stück dann
von der windkraftanlage schützen dafür
aber der hambacher forst halt gefällt
werden musste ich die baumkrone darunter
brauche und das heißt also diese
zusammenhänge die werden kommen gar
nicht die bewertung mit herein als der
positive effekt der windenergie auf die
natur oder auch auf den klimaschutz der
ist bei den ganzen
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen gar
nicht gegenstand und das müssen man das
für die natur und für den klimaschutz
positive sachen dann nehme ich am ende
durch den naturschutz blockiert werden
dass wir ein bisschen absolutes nehmen
aber es ist natürlich nicht nur
naturschutz die liste der gründe warum
der ausbau stadt nähert ist lang es ist
nicht etwas was jetzt plötzlich konnten
ja gar nicht sehen sondern es ist also
praktisch also eine katastrophe mit
ansage
früher wurden sehr viele windparks mit
bürgerbeteiligung gebaut da haben wir
bürger genossenschaft gehabt das heißt
also es gibt bürger windparks das 1000
leute aus der gemeinde beteiligt und
dann habe ich natürlich eine ganz andere
beziehung zu dem windrad jeder umdrehung
ist dann in euro und dann fühle ich mich
gut wenn sich das windrad dreht dann
kommt jetzt der große investor stellt
mir das große windrad irgendwie vor die
nase und dann jede umdrehung 88 und
diese akzeptanz durch kleinere anlagen
durch bürgerbeteiligung wie hat man
überhaupt gar nicht in den mittelpunkt
gestellt und wollte irgendwie möglichst
billige anlagen durch großinvestoren
möglich die großen energiekonzerne
und da hat man die weichen hin gestellt
und es war ein fataler fehler gemeint
als das seit 2007 10
windkraftanlagen ausgeschrieben werden
müssen das gilt auch für kleine anlagen
und es gewinnt der der am wenigsten baut
und am wenigsten förderung braucht und
das macht es den kleinen akteuren wie
den bauern schwer
außerdem ziehen sich die
genehmigungsverfahren in die länge wir
haben bundesländer die weniger flächen
für die windkraft ausweisen und
diskussionen über abstandsregeln auch
hier macht jedes bundesland wassers will
das erste mal dass ich windräder höhere
und genau zum gleichen zeitpunkt ist die
kirche und die ist einfach schon auch
hundertmal lauter aber nächste trotz
ziemlich sowieso eine autobahn ein stück
weiter weg windenergie hat natürlich
auch macht ein bisschen wärmer wobei das
im vergleich zum autoverkehr zum
beispiel auch relativ gering ist und das
möchten viele leute einfach nicht und
deswegen müssen wir vor einigen der
akzeptanz arbeiten alle anderen
technischen probleme oder auch die
finanziellen wir sind gar kein problem
mehr weil der windenergie aber diese
aktion ganz problematik die wir in den
letzten jahren vernachlässigt vielleicht
auch bewusst vernachlässigt wird sich so
schnell vorangeht und das wird uns jetzt
natürlich auf die spitze was meinten sie
das produkt bewusst vernachlässigt also
ein schneller ausbau von solar und
windenergie hat natürlich auch folgen
das war auf der einen seite haben wir
dann natürlich veränderungen im
kundenbereich die man jetzt mühselig
über 20 jahren gestreckt haben die
würden einfach zwangsweisen brüder
kommen
natürlich müssen wir dann auch andere
bereiche abdecken müssen überlegen wie
wir speicher machen wir müssen leitungen
bauen und das ist zum teil auch recht
unangenehme fragen was nämlich auch
stimmt aktuell ist unser stromnetz am
limit wenn wir super viel wind strom
produzieren wie zb bei großen stürmen
das heißt allerdings nicht dass das
nicht ausgebaut werden kann und
speicherkapazitäten nicht aufgebaut
werden können das zeigt zum beispiel
diese studie vom deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung und auch das
fraunhofer institut rechnet vor dass die
energieversorgung durch erneuerbare
energien aus technischer und aus
systemischer sicht machbar ist herr
anheuser befürchtet aber trotzdem das
konzept der energiewende sei nicht bis
zu ende gedacht wir hätten zu wenig
speicherkapazität und zu wenig ausbau
fläche in deutschland
ich habe mich gewandelt von dem menschen
der vor sechs sieben jahren noch in
kameras hinein gesagt hat windkraft da
wo sie sinn macht ja ich sage heute
meint sie macht gern arbeiten sind zu
unsicher sei diese form der
stromgewinnung die wissenschaft
widerspricht herrschenden betont aus
seiner sicht ist alles da wir haben die
technik wäre mir erkennt dass und wir
haben das geld das fehlt einfach nur
daran dass wir nicht bereit sind das
umzusetzen ist kann ich einfach nicht
akzeptieren wenn wir uns weiter
blockieren dass man viel viel teurer
wenn wir einen weg finden wo wir uns am
ende auch einigen und sagen okay es gibt
auch durchaus veränderungen die werden
dann akzeptieren ist es relativ
preiswert wir können ist im prinzip ja
und hier sieht man eben auch was
passieren kann wenn die region das geld
aus levitra wieder reinvestiert ist den
hier auf der brücke in keinerlei die hat
sich zum riesen tourismusmagnet
entwickelt aber wahrscheinlich einfach
mich selbst hätte ich nicht so gut
im rhein hunsrück kreis profitieren die
menschen aktuell von der windkraft die
gemeinden investieren das geld das sie
durch die anlagen gewinnen in
spielplätze seniorenheime oder eben auch
in diese brücke
es scheint so zu sein wenn wir so
weitermachen wie wir es gerade tun kann
deutschland seine klimaziele kaum
erreichen
ja es gibt auch noch hürden und
teilweise berechtigte sorgen von
menschen die gegen windkraftanlagen sind
aber für eine bezahlbare energiewende
aus eigener kraft brauchen wir die
windenergie und noch haben wir die
chance
[Musik]